[Applaudissements]
ce jeudi matin bichkek
des centaines de personnes se
rassemblent pour une nouvelle journée de
protestation lorsque la nouvelle tombe
le président du kirghizistan sort-on
belle jen bykov annonce sa démission
je ne m'accroche pas au pouvoir
je ne veux pas entrer dans l'histoire du
kyrgyzstan comme le président qui a fait
couler le sang en tirant sur ses
concitoyens c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé
de démissionner une décision célébrée
par la foule réunie dans un hôtel proche
du palais présidentiel
épilogue d'une dizaine de jours de chaos
politique et de manifestations émaillées
de violences depuis 2010 des personnes
injuste dirige le pays
nous sommes débarrassés 2 inch'allah
maintenant tout ira bien
nous sommes très heureux nous avons
gagné courage qui existent en est
maintenant confronté à un certain nombre
de questions
tout d'abord il est nécessaire
d'organiser des élections parlementaires
juste et honnête
puis d'organiser un référendum et
ensuite nous déciderons de la forme du
gouvernement présidentielle
parlementaire mixte présidentielle
parlementaire en cause les élections
législatives du 4 octobre dernier
entachée de fraudes et de soupçons
d'achat de voix des élections
finalement annulé après des
manifestations violentes et l'occupation
des bâtiments publics par divers groupes
d'opposants le désormais ex président
avait promis la semaine dernière de se
retirer du pouvoir une fois que le pays
aurait retrouvé son calme et organiser
la tenue de nouvelles élections
parlementaires mais sous pression de la
rue et du premier ministre nouvellement
élu par le parlement ce à dire japarov
qui réclamaient son départ immédiat
soroubat djembé coffre a dû se résoudre
à démissionner c'est à dire japarov
nouvel homme fort du qu'existant à la
réputation controversée lui qui plonge
et jusqu'en début de semaine dernière
une peine de prison de 11 ans et demi
pour avoir participé à une tentative de
prise d'otage d'un gouverneur régional
libéré par ses partisans le 6 octobre
dernier il avait fait annuler sa
condamnation par la justice en un temps
record puis imposer sa nomination au
poste de premier ministre
en sortant ses partisans dans la rue ce
jeudi c'est à dire japarov vient de
revendiquer avoir pris les fonctions
présidentielles
ex république d'asie centrale de l'urss
la plus pluraliste mais aussi la plus
instable le cas existe en a déjà connu
depuis son indépendance le 31 août 1991
de révolution et vu trois de ses
présidents emprisonnés ou exilés